as a chef it's always satisfying to take
a classic dish give it a facelift and
bring it bang up to date
my new version of beef wellington
retains the luxuriousness which made it
brilliant in the first place
but gives it a seasonal lift if you want
to really spoil your friends this
christmas
this is the perfect special occasion
dish
beef wellington has to be the ultimate
indulgence one of my all-time favorite
main courses and it would definitely be
on
my last supper menu my version is a lot
lighter and sexier
and for christmas i'm going to give it
an added twist first off
the fillet of beef now look at it it's
beautiful
first the most important part is to sear
it salt pepper
the fillet is the leanest and the most
expensive cut of beef
it comes from underneath the lower
backbone a part of the animal which has
very little muscle
and this is what makes it such a tender
cut very very hot pan
olive oil and literally roll it around
the pan
we're not cooking the beef we're just
searing it which will really help
to give another layer of flavor and beef
in
lovely now use the side of the pan so
the beef
sears down the back when you tilt it
it's a secret to get it done quickly
it gives that really nice roasted flavor
delicious
once you've got the color very carefully
lift up the beef
and see it on top
and sear it on the bottom out and onto
the plate
english mustard what this does now
it gives it a bit of sort of bit of heat
just lightly brush
the mustard over the beef
so really important that you do this as
the beef comes straight out of the pan
as the beef starts to cool down it
absorbs all that heat from the mustard
horseradish is a really nice alternative
as well just leave that to sit
and relax as the fillet rests prepare
the filling which is called a duck sale
put 700 grams of chestnut mushrooms into
a blender
add a chopped clove of garlic season
with salt and pepper
and blitz
[Music]
christmas wouldn't be christmas without
chestnuts and just crumble them in
to the mushrooms the chestnut's sweet
nutty flavor
works brilliantly with the earthy taste
of the mushrooms and because they
contain more starch
and less oil than other nuts they have a
much softer texture that is perfect for
the filling
that smells amazing smells like
christmas
once the mixture is finely chopped cook
in a hot dry pan
this removes the water from the
mushrooms and intensifies the flavor
[Music]
you can see the water coming out
instantly
such an essential stage really critical
to the success of the wellington that
you dry those mushrooms out and get rid
of all that water
take the mushrooms up even further some
fresh thyme in there which will make it
really nice and light and fragrant
when all the water has been fried off
remove from the pan and leave to cool
then start assembling the wellington
stage one
wrapping the beef phillips first of all
these wonderful slices are parmesan and
little
beautiful overlap it
and set it there so the secret of
overlapping the palmer ham
is to make sure it contains all those
juices
coming out of the beef in the
traditional recipe for beef wellington
a thick chive and spring onion pancake
is used instead of ham
but the palmer ham makes the dish much
lighter and its sweet salty flavor
really complements the mushroom and
chestnut filling
a little touch of pepper no salt because
the ham is naturally salty
just a little twist of pepper
and then from there your mushrooms
and basically mushrooms go on use the
back of the spoon to spread them nice
and thinly
half an inch from the ends rump holes
no hop it every time there's meat
now he comes next lay the beef
on top and very carefully
fold that over now
we're going to lift that up and wrap
the beef nice and carefully so all that
mushroom and parma ham is encasing
the beef all the way over
push it nice and tight roll it
nice and tight and go all the way over
now the secret from here
is to really let the clint film do the
work just nip it
at the ends and squeeze
and what we're doing is just creating
this wonderful sort of cylinder shape
off and then just twist it
nice and tightly and the tighter it is
the more perfect the shape
then place in the fridge for 15 minutes
to firm up
once it's set it's ready for the final
wrap a little bit of tim film
puff pastry beef
now very carefully first roll the puff
pastry over the beef
until the two edges meet then trim off
any excess pastry
and twist the ends together to ensure
the beef is completely sealed in its
pastry case
to set that perfectly and get it really
nice and firm
to make it really cylinder tight climb
from over
and just pull that nice and tight
[Music]
but the big secret behind this is that
it can be done the night before
and the tighter the climb film the
better the shape the more even the shape
the more even it cooks put it back in
the fridge for five minutes
to fill up again then take off the tim
film
always like the perfect christmas
cracker to give the pastry a lovely rich
golden brown color when it bakes
brush it with egg yolk and then finally
you don't have to do this but it's a
chefy thing a little bit decoration
back of the knife down and then just
twist
and mark the pastry when it comes out of
the oven
it's got that wow factor
[Music]
add a generous sprinkle of salt to
ensure the pastry becomes lovely and
crisp
then bake in an oven at 200 degrees for
around 35 minutes
depending on how rare you like your beef
once out of the oven
it's crucial you let the wellington rest
for at least 10 minutes this allows the
meat to relax
and reabsorb its delicious juices making
sure it's tender and
succulent nice and gently hear that
pastry how crisp that is
this is the bit we've been waiting for
oh wow my god
i'm in heaven and for me if you want a
really nice change to roast turkey
this has to be the ultimate for the
table
it smells christmassy the chestnuts the
mushrooms
and that nice crisp pastry on the
outside
look at it i'm ready to die and go to
[Music]
[Applause]
heaven for a really special occasion
i love to serve my beef wellington with
gloriously creamy mashed potatoes
and shavings of exquisite white truffle
my first job on christmas day morning is
to tackle the turkey
and my favorite way to cook it is
roasted with lemon parsley and garlic
it's fantastically aromatic really easy
to do
keeps the meat succulent and tastes
absolutely delicious
for me without question the start of the
christmas dinner is this
a delicious turkey now once this is in
the oven you're halfway there
the secret success behind a great
christmas dinner is making sure this
doesn't turn out dry and is all in the
preparation
now we're gonna make an amazing butter
and this is sort of the start of the the
most important part
keeping that bird incredibly moist soft
butter
a touch of salt and pepper
a little touch of olive oil in there
that stops the butter from burning
next add the zest of two lemons and
their juice
this gives the flavored butter a
wonderful citrus zing
three cloves of garlic turkey's a very
delicate dainty meat
and that's why i want the garlic pureed
so it sort of disintegrates
and flavors a turkey gently without
becoming too overpowering
then add a generous handful of chopped
parsley
wow that smells incredibly light give
that a good mix
turkey's a very very very lean bird and
it dries out
so it's so important to make sure that
we help it
to cook perfectly butter done
now prepare the turkey we'll season the
bird
inside the cavity salt and pepper
next half two onions and pop them in as
they roast
they steam inside the bird giving it a
lovely sweetness
put in the lemon and a couple of bay
leaves for their bittersweet spicy
flavour
[Music]
we're sort of lining the inside of the
turkey with these fantastic
sort of flavours you can see the bird is
upright and it's looking sort of
like it's standing to attention now it's
time to add the flavoured butter just
very very carefully open up the skin
go through over the back of the breast
and keep the skin intact the idea
is to gently loosen the skin with your
fingers so the butter can be stuck
underneath it
now once you've loosened all the skin
off the top of the thighs
turn the bird round and just go through
here again hand up
and just release a little bit but don't
completely break it because i don't want
all that
butter to run out right
from there now take your butter
put it into a ball that smells amazing
lemony citrusy and just
sort of flatten it and stick that in
there
underneath one side now
once you've got it in there pull back
the skin and
just use that to sort of slide all the
way down
what you want to do now is line the top
of the breast with all that butter there
that butter is going to keep the turkey
breast really
seriously moist turn the bird round
and finish covering the breasts with the
butter
turkeys originally came from north
america and they are best young and
plump
my favorite breed for christmas is
either north of black or norfolk bronze
both of which have a wonderful gamey
taste
take the rest of the butter and
carefully massage over the breast
legs and wings
you can do all this the night before and
simply cover the turkey with tim fall
and keep it in the fridge ready to be
cooked on christmas day
into the tray
a little touch of olive oil now olive
oil on top again that protects it gets
that skin really nice and crispy and it
stops the butter from burning
now in the oven at 220 for 10 minutes to
get really nice and brown
quickly in she goes
beautiful
[Music]
that smells fantastic after 10 minutes
take the turkey out of the oven and
baste then cover the breasts
with smoked streaky bacon what i want to
do
is add a little bit more flavor i'm
already starting to think
about my gravy so the bacon protects it
stops it from drying out but it's going
to start
to really give
my gravy a wonderful base
turn down the oven to 180 degrees
this five kilogram bird will feed eight
people comfortably
it needs roasting for two and a half
hours or half an hour per kilo
basting every so often
[Music]
back in and now she's on the way
look at that beautiful it's as pretty as
the christmas tree
right that smells
fantastic wow look at that
beautiful that
is 90 of your work done there to test
the turkey is cooked
stick a knife into the bottom of the
thigh and if the juices run clear
it's done the secret now is to let the
turkey rest
uncovered for two and a half hours as
the meat relaxes
it reabsorbs its juices making it
succulent and tender
plus it'll be easier to carve it might
seem like a long time to let it rest
but remember the turkey doesn't need to
be piping hot
because i'm serving it with hot gravy
that
looks like a million dollars let that
rest
because the flavor will be 10 times more
exciting once it's rested
you